all right let's get into audience
questions Thanksgiving edition first one
is from Ray ray says hey David in the
context of Harvey Weinstein I was at
Harvey Fierstein not at all who is
accused of anything having done anything
wrong Harvey Weinstein Donald Trump Bill
Cosby Roy Moore Al Franken should the
statute of limitations on sex crimes be
abolished this is an interesting
question so first of all the statutes of
limitations on sex crimes vary there's a
patchwork of laws depending on state to
state sometimes there are exceptions
when it is child sex crimes versus sex
crimes against adults and the argument
for abolishing the statute of
limitations would be listen can take a
long time for victims to be ready to
come forward there's huge stigma and
also it can take a long time to identify
the perpetrator so that would be a
reason to extend the statute of
limitations on sex crimes the
counterpoint to that a general one which
applies to many statutes of limitations
would be listen over time evidence
becomes degraded this includes physical
evidence this includes people's memories
right eyewitness accounts and you need
some kind of a limited amount of time
for a case to be put together it just
can't be indefinite the system needs to
work efficiently and there needs to be
something that will drive the the victim
and the justice system to move more
quickly so what do I think I don't
believe that the statute of limitations
should be abolished on sex crimes but I
am up for the idea of extending it I
think that there is certainly an
argument to be made there but I think
that really the an area that needs to be
looked at is tackling other parts of the
problem right which is number one people
not feeling like they can report it
quickly
number two the idea that if they report
it that they may not be taken seriously
or that there will be social
repercussions and other repercussions if
we could work on that we might be able
to reduce the severity of the problem of
people taking a long time to come
forward to tell the story of what
happened to them and part of this Pat
has to do with will they believe me will
it be will it be considered real rape or
is an
did I maybe do something wrong because
of the victim-blaming
yeah mentality that exists so I think
that there's a case to be made for
extending the statute of limitations on
sex crimes but I think there's other
stuff we have to tackle as well you know
what the average length is for the
statute of limitations I'd imagine it
depends on what state it depends on the
state I think sometimes it's as short as
a few years and sometimes it can be as
long as could it be as long as ten years
in some places maybe even 15 yeah and I
mean sure we can still litigate it in
the court of public opinion I mean take
a look at these what eight allegations
against Senate candidate Roy Moore yes
they were from 40 years ago okay but it
has to do with him becoming a u.s.
senator that's important now there's
other ways so the even without extending
the statute of limitations there's still
ways in which these allegations can have
an impact modern day and it hats right
about that but I want to mention
something else to consider what about a
statute that is dependent on the most
recent victim in other words if someone
is accused of having sexually assaulted
others over a 20-year period and the
most recent one is a year ago what if
you're allowed to look at all of the
alleged incidents of sexual assault even
if some of them individually might be
beyond the statute of limitations so for
example with Roy Moore if someone had
said he did this to me last year that
would trigger being able to prosecute
criminally all alleged instances of
sexual assault or something like that
right that's another idea that could be
considered sounds right to me and of
course I'm not a lawyer well by the way
Pat has to remind us on a regular basis
that he's not a lawyer so I'm glad you
mentioned that and I guess I'll take
this as an opportunity to say I'm not a
lawyer either nor would anyone hire me
no and he's not marketing himself as a
lawyer either please the issue with
indefinite right like no statute of
limitations is that for a guilty verdict
you do need to be sure beyond a
reasonable doubt that the person is
guilty and you can make a case after 30
years but the amount of time that has
passed in and of itself could constitute
what we might say as reasonable doubt no
matter how strongly the Witnesses
believe they remember the details and I
think that that's something that
needs to be considered yeah especially
if there are like scientific
breakthroughs that come about like you
know DNA testing did in the 1990s that
could you know either convict or
exonerate someone of that crime no doubt
no doubt about it alright those are my
thoughts on that one